今日はドクターはっちゃんで決めたつ久しぶりだな今日はまずの実験コーナーやって
いこうと思う
みなさん夏といえばなんでしょうそう僕スイカですでこのスイカなんですけどもよく見
られるのがスイカ狩りとか夏力ありますよねは終わりかけなんですけどもいろんな成果
があり私も生きて来て見てきたんだが綺麗に生まれ
たのを見たことないた痛みなんか方掛かっ使ってみたいな感じではれてはなんかこう
ポロみたいな綺麗に成果が追われるところなんですそう滅多に見たことがないんですよ
そこでどうすれば水がもっと綺麗にはれるかなと思いまして
こちら液体窒素を準備しましていきたいそうですね保護に冷却材して使用される液体で
ものとか体とか生体組織につくとその場所が凍傷を起こしてしまいますつまり液体ジス
トってすごいけど超危険なんです今回そんな基金な寺拳法なぜ今ドクターはじめが
できるかというと僕が本当のドクターというわけではないんですけど
九州サイエンスラボのカズ先生という方の監修のもと今回実験を行っておりますので僕
はあ
できるんだイヤホン学的に売れ科学者だな俺これ日本じゃ生きた事実の取り扱いなさい
ではさあ素欠乏危険作業主任者資格が必要な場合がありますので皆
まあにしようと思ってもできないんだなぁと言うで今回ため延長しないでしょ
主流で今回2つ一つか何をしようかと言いますと追加自体ねあの簡単ように命じ
ちょっと柔らかいんですよねなんでこう食べた時にあんまり綺麗に割れないんですけど
も
その水が自体もな看護すべて液体窒素で感じに凍らせてしまえば
スイカ割りでガーンといえばもう追加がじゃない
パーってほっか3人になると思うんですよ
見たくないですかたぶんこのドクターはじめが今からやるスイカ割りが一番魅力的で
素晴らしいスイカ割りになること間違いないですというわけで今回は液体窒素を使って
ガンガンにもう生体組織豪華3大詩歌をスイカ割りの棒もとしている
えっちょっとパーンとモデル的な水影を見せてあげようと思いますでばいいかよでは
早速追加は行った市1町で経済組織ごと方
見ていきましょうシャア何かすればいいんだろセンターでてきますね
それでこの前にですかそこで1対1をかけていきます
もうこのままですよね先生このままですよね
パンツ一枚でだやばいんじゃない
3枚で最低 o
桜や梅ドーナー
てるとかん
若干冷たいけどアラームが高い一かけてやりましょう
なんで打ってくれれば嬉しいと思ってくれ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ねえっます
頭動画でもどうですかねぇ
[音楽]
あっあーっめっちゃ冷たいこの前尾釣ってもいい
ん
[音楽]
b 2 f
me
あーなんかば切ってるん
[音楽]
です鯛カンパチ場所その多分結構凝ってると思ってる
つくばせよかでキーはこのことが現在のでご覧ください
やばいもた風メッサーこの続きがするんですよねただもうできる限り限界まで凍らせ
ます
ほぼを言ってるんだ大丈夫かなーっ
[音楽]
000ほぼいった人のかけ終わりました
まあまですごいぞうちのほうが高じていて聴いて入ってますね
いずれの講座と思うので割ってみましょうマックを致しました
ええええええ
[音楽]
これそれで来ればこの子まで真ん中です
いやー
すー
me
なんでなんでなここ当たったところでねどう見ても凍っているのにくっつけてもいいか
と
tee
うわーっ
[音楽]
いやー
はいというわけでなぜかはれませんでした多分原因としてはもう
効率的って手帳硬くなっちゃってるんですよね片瀬ギテはれたところがもうスピーカー
な表面でしかないんですけど面倒も普通の貼り方というか
皿を割ったような感じになっています
[音楽]
ハッハー子供の時